I think I see a tactic but I have to
calculate it so they're there there
there there there that seems to work
okay let's go
10 minute game
hope you guys are all ready let's get
started with gabo let's play E4
make you ship ship on Amazon
okay scandi it's been a while
we have not okay Knight F6 so this is a
an old variation of the Scandinavian
where black delays delays the capture 95
black wants to take back in the night
and I'm gonna play a line that my coach
taught me years and years ago if you're
seeing this for the first time you might
say well why not C4 defending the pawn
and I'll explain this after the game
the the line that my coach taught me
this is one of the most reputable lines
is is you give this check on B5
okay so this move should make sense that
you're developing with Tempo but now the
move that might be confusing you drop
the bishop back to E2
and black takes on D5 and the point is
that the bishop on D7 ooh now that is
really bad black just gives away a pawn
okay we're gonna take this no idea what
what that was all right now we're just
up upon for no comp
and
the question here is is how we want to
structure our development
we can play D4 and occupy the center but
maybe they're black sc5 so we can
develop a little bit more modestly with
with something like Knight F3
on the other hand
I think D4 is just more ambitious I
think D4 is just more ambitious so I'll
show the
the idea of the line afterward yeah E6
is some sort of weird move
yeah so we go D4 okay it doesn't go C5
so we're fine let's just develop Knight
F3 and then Castle
yeah so we're just up upon no comp
all right so again in such positions
there's always going to be multiple ways
that we can play as Hess would say one
of the best ways of restricting this
Knight is to push the pawn up to C3
and create a pawn chain and make sure
our Central Pawn is well defended we can
also I think some of you might be
attempted to play C4 that I like a
little bit less because the center
becomes a little bit flimsy black and
play like Bishop G4 for example
so if we're pushing the C Pawn I would
prefer to push it to C3
or we could play we could start with the
move Bishop G5 for example
so let's let's start by developing our
Bishop and then based on what black does
we'll make a decision
okay Mr G4 yeah so this is exactly my
point if our Pawn had been on C4 black
would have been threatening this tactic
Bishop F3 and the Knight D4 and because
of the standoff between the Queens you
won't be able to take the Knight back so
it's very important here I think to play
C3
and protect the D4 Pawn against various
Shenanigans now you might say well a lot
of people's reservations about playing
this move is that it's not clear where
to put the Knight but if you watch the
Speed Run long enough you know that
Knight bd2 is completely legitimate
developing move in such positions ooh
so this is a very risky move it allows
us to take on F6
and ruin black structure but but there
is a downside to doing that first of all
we give up our Bishop which is pretty
good Bishop
and second of all black has this idea of
going King h8 and Rook G8 and actually
using the pawn structure to his benefit
thank you John another so Johan another
sub so believe it or not I'm actually
not enthralled by Bishop takes F6 I
don't think this is as slam dunk of a
move as you might think it is
and so we're actually going to refrain
from it and develop complete our
development with ibd2
and maybe a bit later if flax still
allows us to do this we'll take actually
maybe yeah maybe it would have been
better to take immediately who knows
yeah now now he's got his pieces to
pretty good squares okay let's go rookie
one
let's continue improving our position
thank you jaybo for the sub the Jay
dizzler also ooh rookie six
all right so the idea of this move is to
double
on the e-file and put pressure on our
Bishop here and also the fact that the
bishop is on G4 is quite annoying as
well
I have an idea
I have a very interesting idea
I think I see a tactic but I have to
calculate it so they're there there
there there there that seems to work
so the tactic starts maybe I
miscalculated this
we're gonna take on F6 now and we're
hoping for Rook takes FC yes
so does anybody see
an idea here if I calculated it
correctly this might win the game
if I calculated this move correctly it
might win the game so anytime you have a
standoff between these two Bishops right
I've talked about this many many times
there's a particular move that you
should be aware of it's an idea that's
quite common some of you are seeing oops
oh my mouse slipped I didn't mean to do
that oh my God that's hilarious 95 was
the move hello
oh my gosh that's bad 95 I think was
just winning on the spot
yeah I I I was showing and I and I
clicked the wrong Square that's funny
but it's not the end of the world
okay let's go H3
yeah 95 just ended the game I'll show
this I'll show this afterward
okay so we're still up upon
but now we're in a little bit of Danger
on the king side
okay I want to play G4 and get rid of
this pin
yeah let's go G4 let's get get the heck
rid of this pin and then reefie and
Kettle the oh
all right did I just blunder yes I did
okay great
um this is bad
this is really bad I completely forgot
about this move I was discombobulated
after that now slip
yeah I forgot he's got this move okay
now I'm gonna have to pull out a lost
position
yeah this is just pathetic
gotta go here
okay now I have to focus let's see if I
can pull out a swindle this is
completely lost I just wondered
well I was winning and I just made a
stupid move I just made a stupid Mouse
slip and that G4 is just ridiculous I I
didn't see Rook G6
the position is lost but
it's not so easy to find oh and he finds
this
okay he's also just playing Super well
yeah
I guess here is the only move
the 1900s are really good so
they're capable of finding easy moves
okay so I'm down upon and virtually
getting mated but there's no
I don't think there's anything forced
and if he gives me some time I can get
my knight into the defense with like
Knight F3 or 94 Maybe
yeah so so far I've played only moves
Queen H2 King F1
and I don't see the mate I guess he has
Rook G6 then I can go Queen if he goes
Knight he's another really good move but
now maybe I can go Knight E4 get this
Knight into the defense
oh and he's got to be a little careful
because Knight D6 is a threat
wait didn't he blunder
can't I I don't understand
what if I take what am I missing because
the Knight on E7 is just hanging no
he's got a great move though let's see
oh but then I've got a great response oh
my God that's cool so if he takes it
then I take it
if he takes to The Rook I again take the
997. the bishop Angie
okay
but now
I think I have a move
okay Knight back to E4 yeah we save the
Knight and the crucial thing is that if
he goes F5 which I think is going to
happen we have
uh an only move that wins the game
traffic ends but it's not over yet
this guy's totally incessant Queen F3
get get out of the PIN
yeah Knight F6 okay but this is a
terrible move now he just allows me to
take a check now it's over
we can also play Queen G3 and
essentially try to force the queen trade
Queen G3 might be even more accurate
because if we can get a queen trade
then
the game is actually over
wow that was close
now we're just we're just up a piece for
no zero comp and the attack is
evaporated and we're good
Sam I'm sorry for the mouse but that was
disappointing because the tactic was
actually very nice
okay now we can go Knight G5 so we can
actually play aggressively here
and and try to go for the kill and I
think here a lot of people would just
trade
but
in such positions you have to realize
that when you're a piece up
you know at this level you you don't
always just wanna
simplify and bail out
on the other hand if we go Knight G5
maybe he'll go Knight H5
and then Rook G6 so it's a little
annoying so let's take it
I'll show you what worried me about
Knight G5 after the game
so after work F6 again we have a choice
we can take the pawn on C7 because I'm
absolutely not worried about anything
down the G file so I actually
do want to take this Pawn
and I've said earlier in the speed run
that you want to be very careful about
grabbing material when you're let's say
up a piece but if if there's something
you can take for free I also miss this
move but
it's not a
it's not dangerous at all we can just
defend this Pawn
we can go here I guess
I'm playing I'm playing very sloppy
though
okay now we can take I guess on B7 we
can go Rook B1
we can do a bunch of different things
and they're all good
whoa juho with the subs
uh I think Rook B1 and Rook takes B7
makes sense
though I'm a tiny bit concerned about
Rook G6
oh
yeah Rook a seven Queen D5 and then
maybe F3 not ideal
okay so maybe we can cut off his
his Queen with this move C4 trying to
prevent Queen D5
and I I also have a potential tactical
idea we're threatening Rook B8
yeah I think Rook V8 here is very strong
oh but then he takes on G2 oh my God not
easy I should have played rugby on the
previous move
okay so let's play prophylactically
let's ask ourselves what is Black's idea
here well he's got all sorts of
shenanigans like Queen G4 Queen E4 so
what is the root of the problem the root
of the problem is that this Rook on G6
is unbelievably annoying right F3
blenders made in one so what I want what
I'm going to do here is go Rook V3
and get the Rook to freaking G3 and
eliminate this pest on G6
we also have to play fast because this
it's going to take a while for us to
convert this
now because the Rook is okay now Rook G3
and now we're good now we're we're
free of the immediate problems
and all we have to do is convert this by
I think trying to get this C Pawn
forward so what we're going to do is put
the Rook behind the pawn just like in an
end game
and then we're going to start pushing
okay push close our eyes and push
the oh another two subs from juho now
let's go Queen C3 we can also go Queen
E3 but it doesn't matter the key is just
we're pushing the spawn to C7 and then
eventually what's gonna happen is that
he's gonna put a rook on C8 and then
we're gonna chase that Rook away
or queen Away by using one of two
methods if he blockades the pawn of the
queen what should white do here really
quickly because I want to keep some time
on the clock what should white play here
Queen G3 very good so if the queen
blockades to use the method of offering
a queen trade to force the queen out if
he block Into The Rook then we use our
light skirt Bishop to chase The Rook
away very straightforward Bishop H3 if
Rook C8 that's what's gonna happen I'm
pretty sure
okay Queen there it doesn't matter same
thing Bishop H3 we just make sure the
Rook isn't hanging it's not we're good
and we're gonna win
okay so what should we do now
Rook B1 Rook B8 is possible but not the
most efficient the most efficient is
actually just to take on F5
because Rook F5 there's C8 equals Queen
easy enough
let's not make a night by accident
yeah just it's over
and now the most efficient is to
identify that the two pieces are on the
same
diagonal and the easy move here is Queen
to D3 forcing G6 what is the effect of
G6 it opens up the seventh rank allowing
us to deliver laddermate
and
okay King G6 many ways to win here but
because of the pin The Rook as a mobile
so we just go Rook f8
easy GG
okay takes F5 and rookie trade is mate
yeah okay so
I think that was an instructive the fact
that I played sloppy is maybe maybe a
good thing
in a way
so let's deconstruct this real fast
okay so Scandia with Knight F6 is a very
solid line white has multiple ways to
get a small Advantage the reason that C4
is not as good as it looks is because of
this move
C6
and if you take on C6 black takes on C6
and you should know that from previous
speedrun games that this actually is not
a great position for white because if
black has total control over the D4
Square
and opening a parallel that I could draw
with this position is the early F4
Sicilian variation
so if you've been a
conscientious consumer of the speedrun
you might remember the blacksmith here
is D5
that's actually why if you want to play
the Grand Prix attack you should start
with Knight C3 that's the reason
but the point is that after D5 Ed
we don't take on D5 we go Knight F6
then here white again can go C4
but now Black Goes E6 and I've had this
position a couple of times in the
speedrun and black is just better
because total control over D4 White's
position sucks
so similar similar concept
in in this position where Black's gonna
go E5 and Bishop C5 and full comp for
the pawn
hopefully that makes sense now you can
play D4 here
and this transposes into the pawn of
attack of the carocon but
you know that's kind of like cashing in
your lottery ticket for for 15 bucks
that's that's not the best you can do
although if you play the pan-off you can
avoid studying a new opening new line by
playing that
so Bishop B5 check and Bishop back to E2
the point here is that we go D4 and the
bishop on D7 is very awkward right it's
it's cutting connections between All
Blacks pieces
so
what often happens in this position is
the black actually moves the bishop
again to F5
and white gets a slightly better
position I mean
E6 castles Bishop p7
now typically you want to play A3 here
to prepare the move C4 if you play C4
immediately and you allow this very
annoying move Knight before
and you kind of have to go like this to
prevent Knight C2 and this is not
desirable
so you go A3 castles and C4 and white is
slightly better because of the better
central control
and uh just just a good position for
white here
so I would say
this is the simplest line you can study
the theory more carefully
um
and this is a a common opening strategy
again I could draw parallel to the
Catalan
so in the Catalan
which is this line one of the main lines
for black is to go check Force Bishop D2
which is awkward and then return to E7
this is actually considered sort of the
main line
and often white again plays Bishop D2 to
F4 in order to clear up the D2 Square
for the Knight
so
common idea across many openings check
and then back
so E6 I I mean maybe this is a move I I
don't I don't think it is
okay so D4
and here I think black makes another
inaccuracy If You're Gonna Play this
with black you have to challenge the
center immediately I think black's only
serious move here is C5 just trying to
get stuff going in the center you know
but we don't have to take this Pawn
we can just go Knight F3
after Knight C6 we can go either C3 or
Bishop E3 and clearly black has
insufficient compensation for the pawn
so I would have probably played C3
but at least this gets like an isolated
Queen Pawn situation where blackened
claim that he's still doing all right
all right so
maybe maybe D4 is inaccurate because of
C5 we can check with the engine anyways
black doesn't do it we go Bishop D6
Knight F3 thank you Xperia for the prime
we develop our pieces
and after Knight C6 an instructive
moment arises
so I I think some of you when you look
at this position you you notice this and
you you know that's I think why C4 is
such a tempting move because it
threatens a fork
but I was worried about allowing Bishop
G4
why is this move dangerous what happens
if white goes Knight C3 who can tell me
what mini tactic
black has in this position it's not the
end of the world for why white keeps the
pawn Advantage but it's annoying
yeah exactly so
you don't take immediately because here
I can just take with a knight but you
need to take on F3 first
and then take on D4 and if
Queen takes them this is a common trick
discover check winning the queen
so if you if you've blundered this then
you can take on B7 but
our Center is gone this Knight is strong
the bishop is hanging
why allow this type of thing right
White's still better and positive but
this is totally unnecessary this is why
the move C3 I think is a lot more
prudent in such positions but we decided
to develop the bishop first no
particular reason I think C3 would have
also been good
but perhaps here black and play H6 and
prevent us from
putting the bishop on G5 and I was a
little bit worried that we wouldn't have
a good Square for the bishop because E3
is a little passive and it might walk
into Knight G4
F4 is covered and D2 is just terrible so
that was the actual reason I wanted to
start with Bishop G5
so Bishop G4 threatens takes and takes
and necessitates C3
and yeah this is an interesting moment
thank you Adrian Bishop F6
what about H3 first where
I don't really like H3 here because that
creates a hook
and there's all sorts of shenanigans
here with Bishop takes H3 that are
you know there's no need to allow that
G4 is not scary
so why didn't I go for this because
I was worried that he would go King h8
and then Rook G8 and start attacking us
down the G file
and I also don't really want to give
away the dark squared Bishop because now
black has control over these dark
squares uncontested control
so maybe this would have been better but
you know
maybe we can just go like 94 or
something attack F6
another very interesting move here would
have been Knight H4
I actually missed this move and if I if
I saw this move up we would have
probably gone for this line
yeah Knight H4 is a very instructive
mode by the way
what is the point of it the point is to
offer a bishop trade but in a very
particular way because if black accepts
it
then what's who can tell me like why is
this favorable for why why is this trade
good for white
and and why did we put the Knight on H4
so think reverse engineer it like why
would we put the knife specifically on
H4
and I can probably find real life
examples of this kind of idea yeah the
F5 square right we have now
control over the F5 score why is that
important because they have five scores
just really good here so we can now play
Queen H5 or queen F3 and put the Knight
on F5 we've also gotten rid of Black's
light squared Bishop which
diminishes the effect of anything he can
do down the G file
why
because
one of the bishop is one of the vehicles
of Plex attack let's just make a bunch
of random moves here moves like Bishop
H3 become very important
so Knight H4 is I think a super good
move and if black drops the bishop back
we don't go D5 because the bishop takes
D5
but what we do play is Bishop D3 and
queen H5 and this looks terrible
so I missed that
and instead played Knight pd2 and now we
can't do that because the E2 Bishop will
be hanging that's why I got annoyed
when rookie 8 was played
so what you might notice the parallel
that you might notice is the fact that
there's a pin
but obviously if you play Bishop F6 here
well that's dumb because of Queen F6 so
can anybody find a very clever sacrifice
that ties the queen to the D6 Square
yes C5 very good
Ellie the twitch guy thank you
now you play Bishop F6 and you forced G
takes F6 but that's still not the end of
the world for black how did white follow
up
what's the key move and I think this
without this yeah Knight H4 now it's
time for net H4
now black said no I'm not trading these
Bishops because now you've got huge
problems with Knight F5 I'm not sure
this is that good but I you know it
worked
and after Bishop C8 what did I play now
just like in in our game
yeah Bishop not Bishop G for that Bishop
G4 might be good
but Bishop D sorry Bishop D3
yeah Bishop D3
and now Queen H5 is a massive threat so
95 Bishop H7 check
and queen C2 check winning the pawn back
and Black's position is terrible and now
black blunders again
black laser rook h8 and who can find the
crusher
and this is so cool because the F5
square is directly involved in
in everything here
flustered no not Knight F5 check Knight
F5 check doesn't work Bishop takes F5
and if Queen F5 you dropped the knife
deflection right the bishop is
overloaded it's guarding F5 but it's
also guarding B7 so Knight takes B7 yeah
Knight takes B7 not B2 this is B7
because you're playing white and then
you win The Exchange
okay
so that's a I think a good example of uh
this kind of thing happening
so anyways
we played
Bishop F6
and now I'm I Mouse slipped of course
but Knight E5 I think wins the game
so there's three different ways the
black could capture
pieces first of all the easiest this
bishop takes E5 because here we play
Bishop takes G4
attacking the queen attacking the bishop
and black loses a piece
95
is met with d takes C5 and again black
is busted because the bishop is hanging
and if Bishop E2 we just take back and
The Rook defends the pawn or with the
queen but probably The Rook is more
accurate
I think this works
although I think I see a really cool
idea for black here but anyways
if Bishop takes E2 then Knight takes D7
and then we can either take the Rook on
F6 or take the bishop it doesn't even
matter and we're up in exchange
but the the crazy thing is I actually
see something here
after
95
95 d e Bishop E2
so if Queen E2 then black has Bishop
takes E5 at a minimum
overloaded Queen
but if Rook takes C2 I think black has a
beautiful save here
there is Bishop takes E5 anyway
and notice that there's a standoff
between the Queens what does that mean
that means the Knight on D2 is very
vulnerable Black Goes Rook D6
now we can drop back and defend the
Knight But Here Comes the third Rook
Rook d8 or the yeah
and I actually think
I actually think the blacks uh wins the
night back and and equalizes the game
now Queenie one doesn't help right
because of Rook takes D2 and this Rook
is a hero because it's guarding the the
seventh or the eighth
yeah and The Rook is it's overloaded but
you can't actually deflect it so
so maybe 95 wasn't winning I didn't see
Bishop take C5 yeah I just didn't see
this move at all I stopped calculating
here we'll check with the engine
anyways I'm gonna have to go in like
three minutes
okay so we're still up upon here and
this is just a very careless move just a
move out of frustration a mouse slipping
we should probably go 94 or something to
that effect and still white is up a pawn
but I I completely missed I calculated
up to this point and I missed Rook G6
and somehow despite all the pieces here
we can't defend this bishop
it's a miracle that I even have Knight
H4 otherwise we're mated I mean queen G2
is mate
and Knight G5 maybe some of you are
noticing also possible but then Queen
takes G5
and you could say oh and now we have
Queen F3 but
then the Knight on D2 drops
so somehow I managed to get my queen
into the game and the game continues
not sure exactly where black went wrong
well 97 I think is a mistake
so I guess it's not so easy to win this
and then after 94 this blunders a piece
Black's last chance here I guess is to
go Rook E6 to pin the queen
yeah and after Knight D6
there nothing works for black rookie six
Knight back to E4
and if F5 then we have Queen C4 pinning
the rook and winning the game
so
yeah black just forgot about the
importance of the e-file aiming at the
seven Knight
and once this happens that the rest of
the game is
pretty straightforward
we'll check with the engine to see where
exactly black whether black had a win
here I I don't see exactly
I don't see a force twin here
so maybe we're in better shape than it
appeared yeah so anyways one last thing
I wanted to point out once we won the
piece
once we won the piece
I was contemplating this with Knight G5
trying to force the Rook trade on our
terms
and I really didn't like the response
Knight H5 attacking the queen it's a
very instructive move
now you might say well what's the
problem like why can't we just go Queen
G4
well now all of a sudden black has Rook
G6 and the Knight is in trouble we can
play F4 but then there's Knight takes F4
so this leads to unnecessary
complications you can say oh well we can
start with the Rook takes C6
black has to take back but the problem
now is that the f file opens and again
black has Knight F4 and this is a little
bit iffy so
for that reason I just decided to trade
and the last important moment here was
after all of this happens
I think Rook B3 is a really important
defensive move
identifying the source of the attack
right
like what is causing the annoyance it's
The Rook on G6 it's not the Queen the
queen is not
the actual piece that's doing the heavy
lifting
but if you just ignore and go C5
then there's a move like Queen F3 and
all of a sudden white loses
because if you drop the queen back to H2
black we drop the Rook
why not Queen G4 instead of Queen jifa
I'm not sure where can you explain Rook
takes G2 where oh so Rook B8 here is a
very tempting move right because you
want to trade on f8 and then give a
shotgun to get and win the game but
what's going on here there's Rook takes
G2 check and then Queen G4 check
now the king can escape the checks
normally we'd have Queen G3 but now the
queen is overloaded because it's also
guarding the Rogue so black can take it
and probably white is still winning here
because of our passers but black is up a
pawn and the king is close so maybe not
so be very careful about this idea right
of sacking the rook and then delivering
perpetual
here this is totally ineffective because
of Rook G3
does Queen C6 also serve the no Queen C6
blunder is the queen to The Rook
but I think a lot of people would be
tempted to play a move like Queen H2 and
that's too passive it gives up pawns
unnecessarily
and it doesn't solve the underlying
issue so this solves the problem we give
away one Pawn but we keep the other
passer and black is busted so if
blackhead played Queen C5 here we would
have shifted Our Queen to E3 this
technique is remember this technique
when a queen blockades a pawn you can
use the threat of a queen trade to force
the queen out especially if you're up
material because the queen trade is
always going to be good for us here is
that that should make sense
and we use that technique okay Queen C3
is nice because it
it it uh links the queen and the rook
and again uses the queen trade as a
weapon and now Queen G3 is the
the move that makes the magic happen
because black is in a
you know a helpless situation
yeah and then we push and then we
support the promotion square and then we
take and then we win
so I guess even after the mouse slip it
was uh it was an instructive moment last
thing I'll do before I take off
is check 95 with the engine
yeah 95 is actually not winning
so
interestingly
the engine gives in this position the
move H sorry Bishop F6 is a mistake
because of that so we should have just
played like H3
so because of this tactic sorry 95 de
Bishop PT rookie two Bishop E5 and Rook
D6
it turns out that taking on F6 is is a
bad move
interesting
okay no the engine gives like H3 here as
the best move
and then like Knight C4 for example just
keeping the extra Pawn nothing special
here it's like plus two
just because white has such control the
center and the extra Pawn but remember
this line of Bishop B5 check that's a
specific opening takeaway from this game
then
um
important that it's not just a matter of
who controls more of the center when you
have a situation like this you know
building a pawn chain can be a very very
good way to restrict your opponent's
activity
and then obviously interesting stuff
happening with uh oh Knight H4 yeah this
concept very instructive move Knight H4
in such positions could trying to
control the F5 square and hopefully the
over the board example helped all right
guys I gotta take off but uh thanks
everybody I hope you enjoyed the the
morning stream for a change
anyways guys I gotta run thanks for
hanging out good support today
see you guys later
bye everybody